I think there'd be a probably bigger audience for that than there is for our C++ content here. Speaking of which... What? What C++ content? The closest we've had to C++ content is the Python script that you're currently running. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 66, recorded on February 5th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we quickly solve a wordle in record time and then hop into some exciting C++ news. Also, find out which co-host guest got COVID. All right, you ready you ready here we go folks so this is this is the wordle for february 5th 2022 so so do we want to try do we want to try irate instead of a rose i don't really know i
我觉得相比于我们的C++内容，那个应该会有更多的受众。说到这个……什么？什么C++内容？我们离C++内容最近的一次，就是你目前正在运行的Python脚本。欢迎收看ADSP播客，我是第66期，录制于2022年2月5日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）也在，我们以创纪录的速度迅速解开了Wordle谜题，然后切入一些令人兴奋的C++新闻。此外，还能了解到哪位联合主持人的嘉宾得了新冠。好了，你们准备好了吗，各位，我们开始吧。所以这是2022年2月5日的Wordle谜题。所以我们要不要试着……我们要不要试着猜irate，而不是arose？我其实不知道我
want to do a rose we're playing or we're we are traditionalists here we are traditionalists in the hardcore wordle school you ready yeah oh we might get it in two we might get it in two i already have a decent guess but let's see if we can come up with the same guess individually actually i've got two guesses now well let's see i want want probably – hang on. Let me think. I probably – So actually, we're not even – Jesus, we're terrible podcast hosts. Oh, yeah. We have not explained what happened. So we guessed a rose, and we got the A and the O, the first letter and the third letter, both green, both in the correct position. So it's going to be A blank, O blank blank.
想猜arose。我们在玩……我们是传统派。我们是硬核Wordle流派的传统派。准备好了吗？哦，我们可能两次就能猜中！我们可能两次就能猜中。我其实已经有一个不错的猜测了，但让我们看看我们能不能各自独立想出同样的猜测。其实我现在有两个猜测。好吧，让我们看看，我大概想要——等等。让我想想。我大概——其实，我们甚至都没——天哪，我们是糟糕的播客主持人。哦，对了。我们还没解释发生了什么。所以我们猜了arose，然后我们得到了A和O，第一个字母和第三个字母，都是绿色的，都在正确的位置上。所以它会是“A 空格 O 空格 空格”。
I mean, I think I want like an A-L-O word. One of my words is like that. Yeah. Then what would the rest be? A-L-O. You definitely know one of them. Do I? Yeah.
我的意思是，我觉得我想要一个A-L-O开头的单词。我其中一个词就是这样的。对。那剩下的会是什么？A-L-O。你肯定知道其中一个。我吗？对。
The next letter is an N. Oh, no. I was thinking alone, but that doesn't work. An N? Yeah. What goes after an N? I doesn't work. An in? Yeah, what goes after an in? I don't know. What is it? Along. Oh, along, yeah.
下一个字母是N。哦，不。我刚才在想alone，但这行不通。一个N？对。N后面是什么？I不行。一个in？对，in后面是什么？我不知道。是什么？along。哦，along，对。
However, let's not guess that yet because I have another guess that is avoid. I feel like that's riskier. It is riskier, but the question is, we're going for this in two. We've got solid info here. My guess is that the list of words is less than 10. We've got a really good shot of getting it here. Well, we should think of... And the thing is, although avoid is lower, like axiom, except the I would be the third letter so i guess the appeal of void is we get um
不过，我们先别猜这个，因为我还有另一个猜测，那就是avoid。我觉得那个更冒险。确实更冒险，但问题是，我们打算两次就把它拿下。我们这里有确凿的信息。我猜候选词列表少于10个。我们在这里有很大的把握能把它猜出来。好吧，我们应该想想……而且问题是，虽然avoid的排名较低，就像axiom一样，只不过I会是第三个字母，所以我猜void的吸引力在于我们能得到……
i is higher frequency than l and is a vowel and we get i get yeah i guess that's really you get i and then agony agony is another word so here's the thing was we should just take a couple minutes to come up with words that fit this pattern And then choose the one that overlap the most So agony and along Both share an N and a G Which makes Abbott Is that a word?
i的频率比l高，而且是个元音，然后我们得到……我猜就是这样，你能得到i，然后agony是另一个词。所以情况是这样的，我们应该花几分钟时间想出符合这个模式的单词，然后选择重叠度最高的那个。所以agony和along都包含N和G，这让人想到了Abbott。那是一个词吗？
A-B-O-T-T I'm not actually sure if that's an That's a bad That's a terrible guess though Because it's got two Ts I think Abbott is what would be good I feel like A-X-O. What about ATO words?
A-B-O-T-T。我其实不确定那是不是一个……那是个糟糕的……那真是一个糟糕的猜测，因为它有两个T。我觉得Abbott挺好的。我觉得是A-X-O。ATO开头的词呢？
Like a tone? No, no, no E, but... Epoxy? I think that's a word. Although my guess is that's not a valid word or word. But that also, that's the thing is I'm guessing there's a few that end in Y. No, I think epoxy's got to be a valid one. Yeah, like anganine.
比如atone？不对，没有E，但是……Epoxy？我觉得这是一个词。虽然我猜这不是一个合法的Wordle词。但这也……关键是我猜有几个词以Y结尾。不，我觉得epoxy应该是一个合法的词。对，比如anganine。
But what about the ATOs? Is there any ATO? A loft? That has a T and an L. I like that one. What about, are there any A question mark OU question mark words? Allowed? Yeah, good one.
那ATO开头的词呢？Aloft？那个有T和L。我喜欢那个。还有，有没有“A 问号 OU 问号”的词？Allowed？对，好词。
Yeah, yeah, allowed. That's a good one. About? About, yeah, allowed. That's a good one. About. About, yeah. I don't know how to say it as a Canadian, but... So I think we actually have a decent number of guesses here. So what's the most common letters? L shows up.
对，对，allowed。这是个好词。About？About，对，allowed。这是个好词。About。About，对。我不知道作为一个加拿大人该怎么发音，但是……所以我觉得我们这里其实有相当多的猜测。那么最常见的字母是什么？L出现了。
I, L, T. We only got I in one of these, but we have L, T in a bunch. Oh, no, we only have L, T in loft. Well, L shows up three times t shows up twice um so i think it has to be one of the l words yeah yeah um i feel like a loud i mean a loud is probably better than a loft because the f if is i think unlikely or the f doesn't appear in any others whereas for a loud it does appear in other words. You know what? Here's another reason why allowed is nice is because I guess the D might be in place.
I，L，T。我们只有一个词里有I，但我们在很多词里都有L和T。哦，不，我们只有loft里有L和T。嗯，L出现了三次，T出现了两次。所以我觉得它一定是个L打头的词。对，对……嗯，我觉得allowed——我的意思是，allowed可能比loft更好，因为我觉得f不太可能出现，或者f没有在其他任何词中出现，而allowed确实在其他词中出现过。你知道吗？allowed好的另一个原因是我猜D可能就在那个位置上。
Oh, right, right. Yeah. Yeah, let's do allowed. I like it. Yeah, let's do allowed. Okay. All right. Oh!
哦，对，对。对。好，我们选allowed。我喜欢。对，就选allowed。好吧。好的。哦！
Brutal! No. So, aloft? So let the listener know. It could be aloft or it could be along. Let the listener know, though. Oh, sorry. We did aloud.
太残酷了！不是。所以，是aloft？所以告诉听众一声。它可能是aloft，也可能是along。不过还是告诉听众吧。哦，抱歉。我们选的是allowed。
We got the L in place. So we know it's a word that starts with A-L-O. Between aloft and along, I would guess, you know, it's going to be so sad if it was a long, like my first, my first guess was actually the two, but a loft is less likely to be a word-a-word in my opinion. A long is definitely a word-a-word. Should we do it? Yeah, I say we just go with a long. Okay, please, please don't do this to us, a word-a-dle. Oh, God. Oh, no. So we, once again, we tried along and we missed on the N and the G. We need to think about whether there's any other words
L的位置对了。所以我们知道这是一个以A-L-O开头的词。在aloft和along之间，我猜，你知道的，如果是along的话会超级难过——比如我猜的第一个，我的第一次猜测其实是两个，但我觉得aloft作为Wordle词的可能性较小。along绝对是一个Wordle词。我们要选它吗？对，我说我们就选along。好吧，求求你了，求求你别这样对我们，Wordle。哦，天哪。哦，不。所以我们再次尝试了along，但在N和G上猜错了。我们需要考虑是否还有其他单词
that are not, like, aloft because it's going to be embarrassing. Nah, I say we just go for it. You want to just go for it? It's got a T in it. We still got two guesses after this. Jesus. Yeah.
不是那种像aloft一样的，因为那会很尴尬。不，我说我们就直接冲吧。你想就这么冲吗？它里面有一个T。我们在这之后还有两次机会。天哪。对。
I mean, I mean, still pretty decent. Still also interesting to know that if you skip a day, you lose your streak. No, no, that's not true because I haven't done it. I have not done it two days in a row and it said I had a streak. And that may be it. But didn't we, that one said our current streak on the computer is only one. Yeah, you're right. You're right.
我的意思是，我的意思，还是挺不错的。同样有趣的是，如果你有一天断签了，你就会失去连续打卡纪录。不，不，这不是真的，因为我没有断过。我连续两天没玩，它还说我有连续记录。也许吧。但难道我们——那个上面显示我们在电脑上的当前连续记录只有一次。对，你说的对。你说的对。
So very interesting. Brutal. Brutal. Honestly, what can you do though in that situation? We nailed it. All three words. I mean a lot. Well, we could have not played the hardcore strategy.
所以非常有趣。太残酷了。太残酷了。老实说，在这种情况下你还能怎么办呢？我们全猜中了。所有三个词。我的意思是，a lot。好吧，我们本来可以不采取硬核策略的。
Maybe we would have gotten there in three. No, but that's the thing is like we. If we were guessing for more letters for the second guess, what would we have guessed? Wait, let me fill in first. So our third guess was along, and then our fourth guess was aloft. So just in case it wasn't clear, we got it on aloft. Oh, yes, yes. We did get it on aloft.
也许我们三次就能猜到了。不，但问题是，如果我们第二次猜测时为了尝试更多的字母，我们会猜什么？等等，让我先把前面的填上。所以我们的第三次猜测是along，然后我们的第四次猜测是aloft。所以为了以防不清楚，我们在aloft上猜中了。哦，是的，是的。我们确实在aloft上猜中了。
And so here's the thing. We came up with, what was it, eight, nine words. The word that it was was on that list. So good job to us. And I think our strategy was solid. If it was a void, we would have locked it in for sure. And so we would have got it in three. I think the order we...
所以事情是这样的。我们想出了，是多少，八、九个词。最终的那个词就在那个列表里。所以我们干得漂亮。而且我觉得我们的策略很稳健。如果它是avoid，我们肯定就锁定它了。那样我们三次就能猜中了。我觉得我们……
How would we have gotten it in three? So if it was a void and we guessed aloud as our second one, the only word that ended in D on our list other than aloud was a void. But that was what you pointed out. You were like, oh, if we go with aloud, we're locking it in if it ends up being a void. And then the L narrowed it down to only two other words on our list. What I want to know is how many of the words that it could have been did we get? Oh, yeah, yeah.
我们怎么可能三次就猜中呢？如果它是avoid，而我们把allowed当作第二次猜测，在我们列表中除了allowed之外唯一以D结尾的单词就是avoid。但那正是你指出来的。你当时说，“哦，如果我们选allowed，如果最后是avoid的话，我们就把它锁定了。”然后L把范围缩小到了我们列表中的另外两个词。我想知道的是，在所有可能的候选词中，我们到底命中了多少个？哦，对，对。
So here's my – and you know what I'll do? Connor wrote a little program for this, of course. In Python, I'll note. did we get oh yeah yeah so here we here's my um and i you know what i'll do i'll kind of write a little program for this of course in python i'll note he wrote it in python not in c++ this is true i would have written it in python too i would have written it in python or bash you probably would have written it in bash did you use did you use rapids did you use numpy and coonumeric no i did I did not. Alright, then we run it. Interesting, interesting. So here, I'll share a screenshot with you.
所以这是我的——你知道我会怎么做吗？康纳为此写了一个小程序，当然是用Python写的。我得提一下。我们命中了吗？哦，对，对。所以我们——这是我的——你知道我会怎么做吗？我大概会写一个小程序，当然是用Python写的。我得提一下，他是用Python写的，而不是C++。这倒也是。我也会用Python写的。我可能会用Python或Bash写。你大概会用Bash写。你用Rapids了吗？你用NumPy和Coonumeric了吗？不，我没有。好吧，那我们就运行它。有趣，有趣。所以，我给你们分享一个截图。
Are there a lot more words than we thought? There was 30 words using the Scrabble dictionary. Only using Wordle words, there was 12. Where do you get the Wordle word set from? You can just find it on if you Google Wordle word list,
是不是比我们想象的有更多的词？使用Scrabble词典的话有30个词。只使用Wordle词库的话，有12个。你从哪弄来Wordle词库的？你只要在谷歌上搜索Wordle word list，
it takes you to a Reddit, which then redirects you to a GitHub text file. Do you embed it in the script? Oh, it's just, yeah. It's just, no, it's not. It's just a text file in my folder. And by the way, for people who are worried about the New York Times takeover of Wordle, you can just download Wordle plus the JavaScript file. The website is just like, it's all client side.
它就会把你带到一个Reddit帖子，然后重定向到一个GitHub文本文件。你把它嵌入脚本里了吗？哦，它只是……对。它只是，不，不是。它只是我文件夹里的一个文本文件。顺便说一句，对于那些担心《纽约时报》收购Wordle的人，你只要下载Wordle加上那个JavaScript文件就行了。这个网站就像是——全都是客户端渲染的。
It's just the web, one HTML page plus like one JavaScript file. So you can just download it and then like play Wordle forever because the word list, everything is just in that JavaScript file. So even after the New York Times takes the reins of Wordle. So there's 12 12 12 word valid words the first script the words that are in red does that is that the ones that aren't wordle words yeah a hold isn't a wordle word come on so oh we didn't get adopt i guess adopt is one that we should have i would have actually maybe the full the full list of 12 valid wordle words after a rose that go A blank O are
它只有一个HTML网页加上大约一个JavaScript文件。所以你只要下载它，然后就可以永远玩Wordle了，因为词表，所有东西都在那个JavaScript文件里。所以即使在《纽约时报》接管Wordle之后也是如此。所以有12个，12个，12个合法的Wordle单词。第一个脚本里，红色的那些词，是那些不属于Wordle的词吗？对，ahold不是一个Wordle词，拜托。所以——哦，我们没有猜中adopt，我想adopt是我们本该……其实我可能……在arose之后，符合“A 空格 O”的全部12个合法的Wordle单词是：
Aloud, we got that. Along, we got that. Aloft, we got that. Afoul, we missed. About, we got. Among, we missed. Adopt, we missed. Agony, we got.
Allowed，我们猜中了；Along，我们猜中了；Aloft，我们猜中了；Afoul，我们漏掉了；About，我们猜中了；Among，我们漏掉了；Adopt，我们漏掉了；Agony，我们猜中了；
Avoid, we got. A toll, we did not get. A foot, we missed as well. And aloof, we also missed. And actually based on the fact that after allowed, the three valid guesses left were along, aloft, and aloof. We actually should have guessed aloft because it would have told us that it was aloof if we missed. So actually the only reason that my program puts it as the last guess is that it has a duplicate o it always ranks duplicates last yeah that's interesting yeah well we did okay we did okay
Avoid，我们猜中了；A toll，我们没猜中；A foot，我们也漏掉了；Aloof，我们同样漏掉了。实际上，根据在allowed之后剩下的三个合法猜测是along、aloft和aloof这一事实，我们其实应该猜aloft，因为如果猜错的话，它会告诉我们是aloof。所以实际上，我的程序把它放在最后一次猜测的原因是它有一个重复的O，它总是把有重复字母的排在最后。是的，这很有趣。是的，好吧，我们做得还可以，我们做得还可以。
i think we still did it was a song and also to irate tiktoks yeah i don't i don't think you know what's up i don't think you know what's up okay okay? Okay? Wordle TikTok, you have been challenged. Yeah, listen to your ADSP fathers here, you little TikTokers. Maybe we need to start a new podcast that's just about Wordle. I mean, I think there'd be a probably bigger audience for that than there is for our C++ content here. Speaking of which. What? What?
我觉得我们还是做到了，这是一首歌，而且也是为了打发TikTok上的无聊时间。是的，我觉得你根本不懂。我觉得你根本不懂状况。好吧，好吧。好吧？Wordle TikTok，你们被挑战了。是的，听听你们的ADSP老父亲们的话吧，你们这些TikTok小年轻。也许我们需要开启一个新的播客，专门讲Wordle。我的意思是，我觉得相比于我们的C++内容，那个应该会有更多的受众。说到这个。什么？什么？
What C++ content here. Speaking of which... What? What C++ content? The closest we've had to C++ content is the Python script that you're currently running. No, no. So here we go. We're going to wrap up. I might release that all as just one episode because I don't think we can do two back-to-back Wordle episodes. Our listeners are going to get pissed. So now we're going to actually record. But if Wordle's a fad and the fad fades and then you
这里有什么C++内容？说到这个……什么？什么C++内容？我们离C++内容最近的一次，就是你目前正在运行的Python脚本。不，不。所以我们开始吧。我们要收尾了。我可能会把这些全剪成单独的一期，因为我觉得我们不能连着做两期Wordle。我们的听众会生气的。所以现在我们要真正开始录音了。但是如果Wordle只是一阵风潮，而这阵风潮退去之后，然后你
release the second Wordle episode after, you know. It's definitely getting released, but just not are we really going to do two back-to-back episode? I feel like you have to. I feel like you have to. Because, like, Connor, it's become such a big part of our life and our relationship.
把第二期Wordle放到后面发布的话，你知道的。肯定会发布的，但只是我们真的要连续做两期吗？我觉得你必须这么做。我觉得你必须这么做。因为，康纳，它已经成为了我们生活和关系中如此重要的一部分。
And then there was the Wordle phase of ADSP. What tea are you drinking? It is imported merchies from Vancouver, British Columbia, all the way imported to Toronto. And it is Miss Grey. I was going to judge you for your tea, but I've actually had tea in Vancouver. I've had very good tea experiences in Vancouver. On Victoria, well, on Victoria Island specifically.
然后就是ADSP的Wordle阶段。你喝的是什么茶？这是从不列颠哥伦比亚省温哥华进口的茶叶，一路进口到多伦多。这是格雷小姐茶（Miss Grey）。我本来想对你的茶评头品足一番，但我其实在温哥华喝过茶。我在温哥华有过非常好的喝茶体验。在维多利亚——嗯，具体是在维多利亚岛。
Vancouver Island is the name of the island. And Victoria is the name of the city that's on Vancouver Island. But we'll forgive you. You're American. You're American. You're New Yorker. You're from the East Coast. We're at what? Episode 67, 68? episode 67 68 take for us to miss a friday um pandemic didn't do it oh yeah should we should we talk about
温哥华岛是那个岛的名字。而维多利亚是温哥华岛上的城市的名字。不过我们会原谅你的。你是美国人。你是美国人。你是纽约人。你来自东海岸。我们录到第几期了？第67期，68期？第67期、第68期，才让我们错过了一个星期五……大流行病都没做到这一点。哦，对，我们应该——我们应该聊聊
tail end uh tail end of this oh my god yeah we should like we didn't even talk about that that's good yeah so unfortunately um yeah i I got COVID. I like how you were going to start into like, unfortunately, I don't get it. I'm just like, I don't got COVID. Also, too, remember that I made a list of the two things we were supposed to talk about? We haven't talked about either of those. I have a thing that we have to talk about, too. But let's why don't you talk about your COVID experience? Yeah, well, very briefly, I got it. I had both vaccinations, but my booster got canceled on January 17th because of a snowstorm. Thanks, Canada.
这个的尾声……哦，天哪，对。我们应该——我们甚至都没聊过那个，那挺好的。对，所以不幸的是……嗯，我得了新冠。我喜欢你刚才那种“不幸的是，我没得”的语气。我就像，我没得新冠。另外，还记得我列过一张我们要聊的两件事的清单吗？这两件事我们都还没聊呢。我也有件事必须得聊。但不如你先聊聊你的新冠经历吧？对，嗯，简单来说，我得了。我打了两剂疫苗，但我的加强针在1月17日因为暴风雪而被取消了。谢谢你，加拿大。
And it was pretty rough. I got to say, get your boosters, get your shots, and stay healthy because it sucked. Can you still, like, you're okay though now? Oh, yeah, yeah. Thanks to Bryce who didn't send me medical. So Connor tells me he thinks he may have COVID on, like, last Thursday. And I'm like, Connor, like, okay, like, can you get a test? I think you said you can't go out to get the rapid test because if you're feeling symptoms, then like they tell you to not go get the test. And like, I guess you can't get them at the pharmacies up there.
这过程挺艰难的。我得说，去打加强针，去注射疫苗，保持健康，因为这太糟糕了。你现在——你现在没事了吧？哦，对，对。多亏了布莱斯，他没有给我送医疗物资。所以康纳告诉我，他觉得他可能在上周四左右得了新冠。我说：“康纳，好吧，你能去做个检测吗？”我想你说过你不能出门去做快速抗原检测，因为如果你有症状的话，他们会叫你不要去检测。而且我想你在那边的药店也买不到。
It's ridiculous. So like without spending 30 minutes talking about this, you cannot currently. At one point, they were giving them out slash selling them rapid test. Now at the current state of affairs, February 5th, 2022. And this has been the case for the past couple of weeks when I got it. You can't go buy them rapid test now at the current state of affairs february 5th 2022 and this has been the case for the past couple weeks when i got it you can't go buy a rapid test you can go get one administered for 40 canadian but you have to be asymptomatic at most locations some locations so like you're allowed to go get a rapid test if you don't think you have covid basically yeah there are a few locations that do take symptomatic
这太荒谬了。所以，如果不花30分钟来谈论这个的话，你目前——在某个时候，他们会分发或出售快速检测试剂。现在，在当前的事态下——2022年2月5日。在我得病的那几周里情况也是如此。你现在买不到快速检测试剂了，在2022年2月5日目前的这种情况下。在我得病的那几周里情况一直如此，你买不到快速检测试剂。你可以花40加元去做一次检测，但在大多数地方，你必须是无症状的。某些地方——所以基本上如果你觉得你没有新冠，你才被允许去进行快速检测。对，少数几个地方确实接收有症状
individuals and yeah, it's 40 bucks everywhere. And I don't, and I, and you have to qualify for a PCR test, which if you've tested positive, you do not qualify. Like you have to be pregnant. You have to be indigenous or a couple other things. And so like I tested positive on a rapid test and was like, okay, can I get a PCR test test and they're like sorry you don't qualify so so but but the way the way that connor got or the way so so connor tells me like he basically doesn't have access to tests and i'm like connor like send me your address and he sends me his address and i just like immediately stop what i'm doing and i go and i get two of the rapid tests and i live in midtown manhattan so i walk 10 minutes i go into a fedex and i'm like i need this to be in canada tomorrow
的个人，是的，到处都是40块钱。而且我不——而且你必须符合做PCR检测的资格，如果你检测呈阳性，你就不符合资格。比如你必须是孕妇。你必须是原住民或者其他一些情况。所以，我在快速检测中呈阳性，然后心想，“好吧，我能去做PCR检测吗？”他们说，“抱歉，你不符合资格。”所以，但是——但是康纳拿到——或者说方式是这样的——所以康纳告诉我，他基本上没有渠道进行检测，我说：“康纳，把你的地址发给我。”他把地址发给我，我立刻停下手头的事，去买了两个快速检测试剂。我住在曼哈顿中城，所以我步行10分钟走进一家联邦快递（FedEx），对他们说：“我需要这个明天送到加拿大。”
and the fedex people were like were very helpful one of them uh i hope i'm not getting anybody in trouble but i feel like it'd be hard to track this down one of them is like but i might be admitting to an international crime here one of them is like um like filling out the form and then another person comes in they're like whoa no no put down that it's personal effects because apparently if you put down that it's rapid tests then like the canadian border guards hold up the package for some period of time. And so I overnight FedExed this to Connor at exorbitant costs. And like they were like, well, there's two options for like overnighting it. And like one of them is like cost $4 more and gets there like at 9 a.m. to 1 p.m.
联邦快递的人非常乐于助人。其中一个人——我希望我没有给任何人惹麻烦，但我觉得这很难追踪——其中一个人说……我在这里可能是在承认一项国际犯罪。其中一个人说，在填好表格后，另一个人走过来，说：“哇，不行，不行，填上这是个人物品”，因为显然如果你填的是快速检测试剂，加拿大边境警卫就会把包裹扣留一段时间。于是我通过FedEx隔夜寄送给康纳，费用极其昂贵。他们说，“嗯，隔夜寄送有两种选择。其中一种多花4万美元——”不是，多花4美元，在上午9点到下午1点送到。
And the other one is like $4 cheaper and gets there like at 9 a.m to 1 p.m and the other one is like four dollars cheaper and gets there in like the afternoon and like the the the the cost for this shipment was like four dollars was very small relative to how much this is going to cost i'm like sure i'll pay the extra four dollars for it to get there in like the morning and i'm like all excited i tweet connor and connor's like wow i can't believe you shipped it already and so then like the next morning comes and the package goes from like having like a very firm like delivery date to showing up as like pending and they're like operational delay and i'm like what the heck and then they didn't show up for like another day or two so now i'm like
另一种便宜4美元，在下午送到……而这笔运费的费用大概是4美元，相对于这会有多昂贵来说非常小，我说：“当然，我愿意多付4美元让它在早上送到。”我兴奋极了，发推特告诉康纳，康纳说：“哇，真不敢相信你已经寄了。”然后第二天早上到了，包裹的配送状态从一个非常确定的“配送日期”变成了显示“挂起”，他们说有“运营延迟”，我说：“搞什么鬼？”然后他们又过了好几天才送到。所以我现在就想……
oh no not another day or two it was supposed to show up on Friday didn't show up till Monday oh my god I like I want my money back FedEx if you're listening I want my money back like thank you for helping me smuggle these rapid tests into Canada but I expected you to smuggle them into Canada next day Connor needed me and because of you, I let him down. But anyways, you were able to get a test and now are you now COVID testing negative? Well, so that's the thing is I have to take one later today. So I initially tested on a Tuesday. Do you need me to send you more? No, I still have three of them left. So I initially tested negative on a Tuesday because someone who I'd spent a lot of time with tested positive. And I was like, well, I should, if they've got COVID, I should have gotten COVID. And I tested
哦，不，不是又过了一天才送到，它本来应该在周五送到，结果直到周天——直到周一才送到。哦，天哪，我想把钱要回来，FedEx，如果你在听的话，我想要回我的钱。谢谢你帮我把这些快速检测试剂走私到加拿大，但我期望你能在第二天就把它们走私到加拿大。康纳需要我，而因为你们，我让他失望了。不过不管怎样，你总算做成了检测，现在你的新冠检测呈阴性了吗？嗯，事情是这样的，我今天晚些时候得做一个。你需要我再寄给你一些吗？不用，我还有三个呢。所以最初我在周二呈阴性，因为一个我花了很多时间在一起的人呈阴性——呈阳性。我就想，好吧，如果他们得了新冠，我也应该得新冠。然后我检测
negative. And I also felt totally fine. So I was like, okay. Then like Wednesday felt a tickle in the back of my throat. Thursday was definitely sick. And that's when I was like, well, most of these places, I can't go get a rapid test. You FedExed, didn't show up on Friday. So I went and got another rapid test, tested positive. And then I took one of Bryce's rapid tests this past Tuesday, which is we're recording this on a Saturday right now, and still tested positive, even though my quarantining period was done.
结果是阴性。而且我感觉完全没事，所以我想，好吧。然后周三的时候，我喉咙后面感觉有点痒。周四的时候我绝对是病了。那就是我心想的时候，好吧，在大多数地方，我都去不了进行快速检测。你用FedEx寄的快递周五没到。所以我去做了另一个快速检测，结果呈阳性。然后我在本周二用了布莱斯的一个快速检测试剂——我们现在是在周六录音——结果依然呈阳性，尽管我的隔离期已经结束了。
And supposedly Omicron, it's supposed to disappear from the test results. stay tuned listener i'm doing fine but um take your shots get your boosters i went and got my booster on wednesday aren't you supposed to not get the booster when like when you have covid uh so no like the quarantine period was supposed to be you you know, five days now and you're, you're supposed to still get it. And then Canada came out and issued on Friday, two days after I got the booster announcement saying, if you've just been infected, don't get it for eight weeks. But that, that recommendation didn't come out two days until after, after I got the
按理说，对于奥密克戎（Omicron）来说，它应该从检测结果中消失才对。敬请期待，听众朋友们，我状态很好，但是……去打疫苗吧，去打加强针吧。我在周三去打了加强针。你不是说得新冠的时候不应该去打加强针吗？呃，没有，隔离期现在应该是五天了，然后你还是应该去打。然后加拿大在周五，也就是我宣布打了加强针的两天后发布了公告，说如果你刚被感染，八周内不要去打。但那个建议直到我打完加强针的两天才发布。所以，你知道的，情况一直在变。但我现在觉得，我差不多已经完全免疫了。
booster. So, you know, constantly changing. But I think I'm, like, super inoculated at the moment. Yeah. And to wrap up this episode. Wait, wait, wait. In lighter news, Eric Niebler's keyboard has been found. I don't think we technically get to take credit, but we're going to take credit.
好的，为了结束这一集。等等，等等，等等。有一则较轻松的消息，埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）的键盘找到了。我觉得我们严格来说不能居功，但我们还是决定居功。
Oh, yeah. We're going to. Oh, we're definitely taking credit. Like, the keyboard was missing we announced on the third most popular c++ podcast soon to be second soon to be second we're coming for you cpp chat we announced that his keyboard was missing and then magically somebody some good and wonderful and excellent person who I desperately hope listens to this podcast found the keyboard and sent it back to Apple and Apple sent it to Eric. And now Eric has his keyboard.
哦，对。我们要。哦，我们绝对要居功。键盘丢了，我们在第三受欢迎的C++播客上宣布了这一消息——很快就会变成第二受欢迎的。很快就会变成第二，我们来了，Cpp Chat。我们宣布他的键盘丢了，然后奇迹般地，某个人——某个善良、美妙、优秀的人，我极其希望他听了这个播客——找到了键盘并把它寄回了苹果，然后苹果把它寄给了埃里克。现在埃里克有他的键盘了。
Do you mean Facebook or do you mean Apple? Facebook. Facebook is what I meant. Speaking of Apple. Yes. I'm probably thinking of Apple because. You can say it because this won't come up for like a month. My dear colleague, Olivier, who's been at NVIDIA for 20 years or 19.7 years.
你指的是Facebook还是苹果？Facebook。我指的是Facebook。说到苹果。是的。我可能一直在想苹果，因为……你可以说出来，因为这要过一个月左右才会播。我的亲爱同事奥利维尔（Olivier），他在NVIDIA呆了20年，或者说19.7年。
I'm going to round up on his behalf. If it was me that was leaving NVIDIA after being here for 19.7 years, you know me. I would just say I've been here for 20 years. But Olivier left NVIDIA this week and is going to Apple, where he will be the director of GPU compute at Apple. So I'm very excited for him. And so that's probably why I have Apple on the mind. Yeah. Congratulations, Olivier.
我替他四舍五入一下。如果是我在NVIDIA呆了19.7年后离开，你们了解我。我只会说我在那里呆了20年。但奥利维尔这周离开NVIDIA去了苹果，他将在苹果担任GPU计算总监。所以我为他感到非常高兴。这大概就是我脑子里一直想着苹果的原因吧。是的。恭喜你，奥利维尔。
It'll be sad to see you go. We'll still see you at conferences. We're going to have you on this podcast at some point, and then it won't be three guys who work at NVIDIA. It'll be two guys who work at NVIDIA and one guy who works at Apple. Yeah. So before Olivier left, literally in his last hour or two of being an NVIDIA employee, I'd been badgering him for the past week or two,
看到你离开会让人难过的。我们还是会在会议上见到你的。我们会在某个时候邀请你上这个播客，到时候就不是三个在NVIDIA工作的小伙子了，而是两个在NVIDIA工作的小伙子和一个在苹果工作的小伙子。是的。所以在奥利维尔离开之前，就在他作为NVIDIA员工的最后的一两个小时里，过去的一两周里我一直在死缠烂打地找他，
like, send me all your slides. Make sure that I have all your slide decks and so then he sent me like three emails with like all of his slide decks and so now like i have like an email folder that's just like olivier slide weaponry and it's like i feel like i've been given like the crown jewels yeah it's like i have this great responsibility to use these slides. Because Olivier was amazing at taking information and turning it into very effective weaponized slides that could just convince anybody of anything. Yep. And so now I have inherited those slides. Yep. Eric Kneebler, Facebook and the keyboard,
比如，“把你的所有幻灯片都发给我。确保我拥有你所有的幻灯片。”然后他给我发了大约三封邮件，里面包含了他的所有幻灯片。所以现在我有一个邮件文件夹，里面全都是“奥利维尔的幻灯片武器库”。就感觉我被授予了王冠上的明珠一样。是的，就好像我负有重大责任，要好好利用这些幻灯片。因为奥利维尔非常擅长将信息转化为非常有效的武器化幻灯片，能够说服任何人相信任何事。是的。所以现在我继承了那些幻灯片。是的。埃里克·尼布勒、Facebook和那个键盘，
Olivier and Apple. And we also have one other piece of news. Future guest. Who? Started at NVIDIA. Oh my God. Yes. Andre will be on this podcast
奥利维尔和苹果。我们还有另外一则新闻。未来的嘉宾。谁？曾在NVIDIA工作过。哦，天哪。是的。安德雷将会在不久的将来上这个播客，
at some point in the near future because Andre Alicandrescu now works at NVIDIA. Has that been like, is that common knowledge yet yeah yeah it's on linkedin there's a twitter thread that talks about it yeah we can talk about that yeah andre so we now have andre eric um oh like if you if y'all think i am done hiring c++ people let me tell you i have plansVIDIA has the best C++ team out there. And if you want to come and be a part of that team, you come contact me. You let me know. You let me know. I'm hiring. Yep. Pretty exciting. Maybe we'll even have to... Actually, we'll let the listener wait. The listener's now listening to this sometime in March, and we're recording this at the beginning
因为安德雷·亚历山德雷斯库（Andrei Alexandrescu）现在在NVIDIA工作。这已经是……这已经是众所周知的常识了吗？是的，是的，它在领英（LinkedIn）上，有一个推特线程在讨论它。是的，我们可以聊聊这个。是的，安德雷。所以我们现在有了安德雷、埃里克……哦，如果你们觉得我已经招够了C++人才，那我告诉你们，我有计划。NVIDIA拥有最棒的C++团队。如果你想来成为那个团队的一员，你就来联系我。让我知道。让我知道。我在招人。是的。挺令人兴奋的。也许我们甚至不得不……其实，我们会让听众拭目以待。听众听到这个的时候大概是在三月份，而我们是在二月初录音的，这意味着无论我们什么时候和安德雷录音，等它播出来的时候大概已经四月或五月了。所以我本来想说，哦，我们也许应该请他上来然后直接剪辑进去。我们会把他剪进去的。我们会让他插队，但不了，我们还是让听众等一等吧。你得——你得——你知道的，这就是成为准全美第二大C++播客的待遇。内容实在是太精彩了，但你得耐心等待。我觉得我们迎来了令人兴奋的一年，因为你知道的，在嘉宾方面，我们将邀请安德雷，我们将邀请托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Erd）。我觉得我们应该邀请……
of February, which means that whenever we do record with Andre, it's going to be like, it's going to be like April or May by the time it's out. So I was going to say, Oh, we should maybe get them on and then just like cut them in. We'll cut them in. We'll let them jump the line, but no, we'll let the listener wait. You gotta, you gotta, you know, that's what happens when you are the soon to be number two C++ podcast. The contents, it's just so juicy, but you got to wait for it. I think we got an exciting year ahead of us because, you know, like guest-wise we're going to have Andre, we're going to have Tony Van Erd. I think we should have.
我们还得请回戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）。是的，我们一定要请凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）来。是的。我们要拓展业务。我们要请一些Rust领域的人。我们可能还会请一位Go领域的人。一位Go领域的人。一只地鼠（Gopher）。
We still got to have back Dave Abrahams. Yeah, we got to have Kate Gregory on for sure. Yeah. We're going to branch out. We're going to get some Rust folks. We're going to maybe bring on a Go folks. A Go folk. A Gopher.
Go 1.18发布了。他们现在有了泛型。这是个大新闻。大新闻。那是Go语言最大的问题。我们今年夏天某个时候会请钱德勒（Chandler）回来。是吗？是的。
Go 1.18 came out. They got generics now. It's big news. Big news. That was the big problem with the Go. We're going to have Chandler back sometime this summer. Are we? Yeah.
你还不知道为什么，但到时候你就知道了。到时候你就知道了。这会很酷。天哪！
You don't know why yet, but you'll see. You'll see. It's going to be cool. Holy smokes. we yeah you don't know why yet but but you'll see you'll see it's gonna be it's gonna be cool holy smokes even even even some juicy stuff that i don't know about that uh bryce is keeping from me well you know it's you know chandler's got the best stories he's got the best stories does he have the best stories like after sean he probably has the best i mean sean almost killed a couple people but like sean's just such a next level. Not wait. Let me roll that back.
我们——是的，你还不知道为什么，但到时候你会见分晓的，你会看到的，这将会非常酷。天哪！甚至还有一些连我都不知道的劲爆内容，布莱斯一直在对保密。好吧，你知道的，钱德勒总是讲最好的故事。他有最好的故事。他有最好的故事吗？除了肖恩（Sean），他大概是最棒的——我的意思是肖恩差点弄死好几个人，但肖恩就是那种下一级别的人物。等一下。收回刚才的话。
Let me roll that back. Near misses on people's deaths does not necessarily make a great story. Please do not go out and nearly kill people to get on ADSP. That's not. We do. We do not endorse. We are not legally near death experiences to get on this podcast but that said it better be good it better be really good
收回刚才的话。差点导致别人死亡并不一定能构成一个精彩的故事。请大家千万不要为了上ADSP节目而去差点弄死别人。那不是。我们不。我们不予背书。我们不从法律上认可通过经历生死边缘来上这个话语播客。但话虽如此，这个故事最好很精彩，最好真的非常精彩，
like we we we take no responsibility but um like if you have a great story about a time that you smuggled something across the canadian border let us know yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna get arrested when i come to cpp north the little the little horse police are gonna be waiting for me at the border this is the beautiful thing is that we don't really take this podcast too seriously. Like our other podcast, this is a random tangent because this landing of this episode
就像我们——我们不承担任何责任。但如果你有一个关于你如何把某样东西走私过加拿大边境的精彩故事，请让我们知道。是的，我——我来参加CPP North的时候肯定会被捕的。那些小小的骑警会在边境等着我。这就是美妙之处，我们其实并没有把这个播客看得太严肃。就像我们的其他播客一样，这是一个随机的题外话，因为这一集的结尾
is real rough. I wanted the executive producer, Bob Terrio, to cut in a clip of the Internet is Evil song from the Bo Burnham special or whatever, or Internet is Evil song from the Bo Burnham special or whatever, or Internet is Everywhere.
真的非常生硬。我本来想让执行制片人鲍勃·泰里奥（Bob Terrio）剪辑一段博·伯罕（Bo Burnham）特辑里的《互联网是邪恶的》（Internet is Evil）歌曲片段什么的，或者《互联网到处都是》（Internet is Everywhere）歌曲片段什么的。
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. Could I interest you in everything all of the time? A bit of everything, all of the time Apathy's a tragedy and boredom is a crime Anything and everything, all of the time Could I interest you in everything, all of the time A little bit of everything, all of the time Apathy's a tragedy and boredom is a crime
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。Could I interest you in everything all of the time? A bit of everything, all of the time Apathy's a tragedy and boredom is a crime Anything and everything, all of the time Could I interest you in everything, all of the time A little bit of everything, all of the time Apathy's a tragedy and boredom is a crime
Anything and everything, and Anything and everything and anything and everything and anything and everything and all of the time. And he was worried about, like, copyright. And I was like, my guy, nobody listens to our, like, in the scheme of podcasts, nobody's like, the podcast
Anything and everything, and Anything and everything and anything and everything and anything and everything and all of the time. 而他一直担心诸如版权之类的问题。我就对他说：“老兄，根本没人听我们的——在所有播客的大格局里，根本没人——播客
police are not listening to a Raycast and ADSP. Don't worry, if we do get sued, my mother's a lawyer and she'll, she'll represent us. Right, mom? We, that's awesome. We actually have an ADSP. We've got, we've got a legal team. Yeah. Yeah. So, so really like. Bryce's mom's our legal team. What's up? What's good? Come at us lawyers. I don't know if any of you know my mother, but you know me and you know that I'm pretty, pretty, I'm a handful. So like before you, before you think about suing us, think about whether you want to deal with the lawyer version of me. Um, like,
警察才不会去听Raycast和ADSP呢。别担心，如果我们真的被起诉了，我妈妈是律师，她会代表我们出庭。对吧，妈妈？”我们——这太棒了。我们其实有一个ADSP。我们有——我们有一个法律团队。是的。所以，真的是——布莱斯的妈妈就是我们的法律团队。怎么了？有什么好说的？冲我们来吧，律师们。我不知道你们当中有没有人认识我母亲，但你们了解我，也知道我挺——挺难对付的。所以，在你们考虑起诉我们之前，先想想你们是不是想对付律师版的我。呃，
yeah, cause that's a little, a little much. Yeah. That's awesome. We've got a legal, we've got a legal team here at ADSP, the podcast. It's Bryce's mom. And that's like, it sounds like, you know. And if you're like a big company, Connor's dad is going to go find like whatever stuff you did. Connor used to tell me these stories about how like he'd meet, like people would be like, the companies would be like terrified of his dad. So don't mess with this podcast. Yeah, that's true. My dad's a journalist that when
是的，因为那有点——有点过头了。这太棒了。我们在ADSP播客这里有一个法律团队。那就是布莱斯的妈妈。这听起来就像是，你知道的。如果你是一家大公司，康纳的爸爸就会去找出你做过的各种事情。康纳过去经常跟我讲这些故事，说人们会怎么样——公司会如何畏惧他的爸爸。所以别惹这个播客。是的，千真万确。我爸爸是一名记者，当
certain when he shows up like red flags get raised in corporate whatever and emails get sent is oh oh shoot gourd hookstra is uh he's on the phone this isn't good this isn't good so unless you want that so so so stay away from us unless you want that to happen to you. Yeah. But seriously, please don't sue us. Well, so what are the clips? We've got the Fiddler on the Roof tradition. Did you listen to that one? I guess I have to now.
特定的时候他出现，在企业的某种事务中就会拉响红警，邮件就会发出：“哦，哦，糟糕，戈德·胡克斯特拉（Gourd Hookstra）正在打电话，这可不妙，这可不妙。”所以除非你想那样——所以所以所以离我们远点，除非你想让那种事发生在你身上。不过说真的，请千万不要起诉我们。好吧，那么有哪些剪辑片段呢？我们有《屋顶上的提琴手》（Fiddler on the Roof）的传统。你听过那一集吗？我想我现在不得不听了。
It's the best, man. I cut in a whole like 60 seconds of Fiddler on the Roof. I think that's domain now i think we're good there yeah but we're well okay but where'd you get the clip from uh i mean i'm not i'm not gonna give the people that want to sue us material if you want to sue us you're gonna have to do your work okay and we're gonna counter sue you real fast because we've got a legal team here at ADSP, the podcast. And, you know, what do you think you and your mom do all that yoga for? It's to be nimble and quick. Boom.
太棒了，老兄。我剪辑了整整60秒的《屋顶上的提琴手》。我觉得那现在属于公有领域了，我觉得我们没问题了。是的，但是——好吧，那你从哪弄来的剪辑片段？呃——我的意思是，我不会把材料送给那些想要起诉我们的人。如果你想起诉我们，你得自己去做工作。而且我们会很快反诉你，因为我们在ADSP播客这里有一个法律团队。而且，你觉得你和你妈做那么多瑜伽是为了什么？就是为了保持敏捷和灵活。砰！
Countersuit. Slander. All right. Jeff, I hope that answers your question. Thank you for putting up with us, Jeff. uh we love you we love all of our listeners tune in next time to find out who jeff is and hear our answer to his question thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
反诉。诽谤。好吧，杰夫，我希望这解答了你的问题。谢谢你一直包容我们，杰夫。呃，我们爱你，我们爱所有的听众。请下次收听，来看看杰夫是谁，并听听我们对他的问题的回答。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。